(bump)
- Wait hold on.
- Ow.
- You have a ring on.
(upbeat music)
- Dr. Mike here with the
lovely Eva from My Life as Eva.
- Yay!
- We're gonna talk about
Eva's disbeliefs and beliefs
about medicine and we're
gonna set them straight.
These aren't planned by the way.
- So first question is,
everyone always says
when you go out to eat they're like,
"Oh don't touch that sugar
because sugar gives you cancer.
"Leaving water bottles in
your car causes cancer.
"Drink out of a glass cup,
plastic cups cause cancer."
Are all those things
able to cause me cancer?
Should I just live my life
not touching anything?
- If you constantly
live your life thinking
whatever you do you're gonna get a cancer,
that's not a way to live life.
Drinking out of plastic, how bad is it?
It's really not that bad.
I mean unless you're using
a cheap piece of plastic
and you're reusing water
bottles all the time,
you're throwing them in the microwave.
Yes, that's not great.
If you just live in a
balanced, normal way,
you're gonna be fine.
One down.
- That makes me feel better.
(laughing)
- Question dos.
- Question two.
I'm a girl, which means that
I can get breast cancer.
I'm still really young and I'm tiny
and I've got these small boobs.
What time in my life
should I start wondering
if I should go to the doctor
to check up on all those things?
- Guys get breast cancer too!
It's not just for women.
Really what you can do as a female
is starting at the age of 40,
you want to start getting
mammograms, right?
Do you know what a mammogram is?
- No.
- C'mon.
- They touch your boobs?
- So a mammogram is a scan
that looks at your breast tissue
that tells you if you have some sort
of irregularity there.
Before the age of 40,
what you should do is
you should be able to know
what's normal for your breasts.
Hey, this bump wasn't here before
or this pain wasn't here before,
or this discoloration wasn't here.
Also, important to note,
if you had someone very
young in your family
have breast cancer, that might lead me
to start testing you a little bit earlier.
But you're doing a great job so far.
Bam!
- I learned.
- All right two for two.
Knowledge is seeping
into her mind.
- Knowledge is power.
I have friends that model,
and they always drink carrot juice
before a day of a shoot to
make their eyes sparkle.
- Sparkle?
Okay.
Carrot juice does not
make your eyes sparkle.
Carrot juice does contain
a lot of vitamin A.
If you have enough vitamin A,
you vision will stay healthy.
The reason we say that is if
you have too low vitamin A,
you're vision gets worse.
Some of these people, they go overboard
and they start doing things too much.
- Yeah.
- You know what happens if
you eat too many carrots?
- Who, what?
- You turn orange.
- No you don't.
- So wait, if I eat a lot of carrots
will I get a spray tan, like a carrot tan?
- Yes, you will have a carrot tan.
A carrot tan.
- Okay, so I'm allergic to cats,
and whenever I'm with my cat.
- You have a cat?
How are you allergic, Paris?
- I love cats.
(meowing)
I love her so much, but
when she gets a lot touchy,
I have to take Benadryl because
I need to clear my sinuses.
I have back pain, but I
want to drink wine later
or champagne for a mimosa
but I'm on aspirin.
When you take any sort of medicine,
and says don't drink
alcohol, am I going to die
by drinking alcohol?
- I will answer it in
a very universal way.
- Okay.
- Will you die from one glass of alcohol
with aspirin or Benadryl or
anything over the counter?
No.
Is it good to drink alcohol
with a lot of these pills?
Probably not.
Why aspirin?
- Like if my back hurts.
- But why aspirin?
- I don't know, I don't
have anything else.
- Did you watch too
many Bayer commercials?
- Yeah, I love Bayer.
- Oh my god, you see what happens?
Why not acetaminophen like Tylenol?
- Acetaminophen.
♪ Tylenol ♪
♪ Wine, Tylenol ♪
(laughing)
I don't know, Tylenol
feels like a baby one.
I need hardcore stuff.
- Hardcore stuff.
- I need that 500 milligrams.
- Tylenol is only a pain and fever reducer
but does not work on inflammation,
and aspirin actually
works on your platelets.
Do you know what platelets are?
- Yeah.
- What?
- The little circle.
- Fats.
- The little circle things
that air in your blood.
- That do what?
- They're circles.
- They're not really circles.
- They're little ringlet things.
- Ringlet, sure.
Kids at home, don't
drink alcohol with drugs.
I'm just saying this to her
because she's too crazy of a party animal.
- I'm an adult.
- She's almost an adult.
- You're not even 21 yet.
- I'm 22.
- No you're not.
- Yes I am.
- ID check.
- How easy is it to get
addicted to something
like NyQuil or pain killers?
Does it take five days,
does it take a month of doing it daily?
Because I'm not trying to
get addicted off pain killers
because my back hurt one day
and suddenly I'm addicted when I wake up.
- Addiction to over-the-counter
pain medications
like Tylenol, Advil, it can happen.
You technically can get
addicted to anything.
I mean there's sex addictions out there.
So people get get addicted
to literally anything.
But, is it likely?
No, because generally those medications
don't have addictive properties,
meaning that when your
body doesn't get them,
your body doesn't go through withdrawal.
Opioid medications like
Oxycodone, Percocet,
those you can get addicted
from one-time use.
So it's very important
that you only take them
when it's absolutely absolutely necessary.
Boom!
- Woo!
I have been working out a lot more.
- I can tell.
Guns.
She's hiding my arm behind hers.
- And I've been eating healthy
and I've been trying to get my nutrients,
but being a vegan, I think it's maybe hard
to get a lot of my vitamins, maybe.
I've been taking a multivitamin thinking
that's good for me.
- Vitamins for the average healthy person,
a multivitamin, vitamin D, vitamin E,
all the vitamins out there.
Taking them does not help
you stay healthy longer.
Doesn't prevent any illness,
doesn't cure anything,
unless you happen to be
that small minute population
that has a deficiency.
- How important is it
to get a tetanus shot?
I like to hang out in Hawaii, surf,
cut my foot on some rocks, whatever.
- Okay, wait.
You like to cut your foot on rocks?
Is that some new teenage thing
that you guys are doing now?
- Rock cutting.
- Really?
- No.
- Okay.
- Sometimes I cut my foot on a rock
and then you bandage it up, whatever,
salt water cleans it out.
- Troof.
- I'm a mountain man.
When was the last time
you got a tetanus shot?
- I can't remember.
- All right, come on.
- I can't.
- When's the last time you
got your vaccines done?
You were a kid.
- I literally can't remember,
I don't remember at all.
- You see what happens?
Tetanus shot, you need it every 10 years.
- Okay.
- So it's not even a vaccine
that you need to get it so often.
But now we're giving a
special type of tetanus shot,
where it's not only
protecting you from tetanus.
It's called a Tdap.
It also protects you from
diphtheria and pertussis.
Fancy words.
Pertussis which causes whopping cough.
- Whoop, whoop.
- Yep.
Another thing about tetanus.
Why risk getting a horrible
tetanus infection in your leg?
You can get gangrene and lose a toe
or finger or a arm, a leg.
- Okay, I want the tetanus shot.
- See, get the tetanus shot.
It's like a little poke.
- Give it to me right now.
I have heard a lot of
people do yoga and say,
"Ever since I started yoga
"my health has gotten so much better
"and my back is healed."
So I'm hearing all these
things about natural things
that you can do with working out and stuff
that gets rid of health things.
Can you actually cure
medical conditions and pain,
like meditating, working out, eating kale?
- Kale is cool.
Whoever is the marketer
that made kale a super food
is a genius.
If you could do the same
for my Instagram and YouTube
and Eva's as well, please do it,
because you killed it.
- Kale yeah!
- Yeah, kale yeah, oh that's a good one.
Number one, diet and exercise
can not only help cure
some of your illnesses,
but they can also prevent.
Those who exercise have a lower
risk of getting depression.
Those who exercise have a lower risk
of developing Alzheimer's later in life.
You could lower your cholesterol levels
better than you can than with medicine
just by exercising.
There's no such thing as a cure-all.
There's no fountain of youth.
But exercise comes closest.
Yes, do yoga, do sports,
make your heart go crazy.
- Make your heart happy.
- Yes.
- I love green juices,
like love green juices,
love all the detox juices and all that.
Do detoxes really work
and are they worth doing?
Apple, kale, banana, spinach, ginger.
Is that actually gonna help me?
- Juices themselves are not bad.
But they do contain a lot of sugars,
so if you're diabetic or eating
a lot of sugar in general,
you have to keep that in mind.
As you probably know that in order
to make a glass of orange juice,
it doesn't just take one orange, right?
It takes a few.
Also, when you eat a fruit,
you get some fiber along with it.
When you eat fiber, it
makes you feel fuller,
it also prevents the absorption
of some of that sugar,
so you don't absorb it and it
doesn't go into your blood.
When you drink the juice,
it just goes straight into your body.
It gets absorbed as simple sugars
and can cause you to become diabetic
if you have it too often.
They have some great
vitamins, some great minerals
so a juice every now and then.
Again with a bit of
reason, balance, it's fine.
But, detoxes.
What a marketing play.
Your body naturally cleanses itself.
Your skin sheds it's lining every day.
Your intestinal lining sheds
and your body replaces it with new lining.
There's no need to detox.
My humble opinion, and based
on what research has show,
because that's where
my opinion comes from.
There's no benefit to doing any of this.
But if you wanna have a green juice,
have it after the gym,
because that's the time
it's okay to have some sugar.
Well Eva, I didn't know you
were such a curious soul.
- I'm very curious.
- That's good to see that
the younger generation
has a thirst for medical knowledge.
- Thirst for knowledge.
- Everybody should tune in
to My Life as Eva's channel
because there's also a cool video
that we made earlier
today that you will love.
- On my channel.
- And if you obviously have any questions,
any comments about things
we talked about today,
leave a comment down below,
I'll make sure to answer it.
And if you haven't yet,
click that subscribe button.
- Woo!
Bye!
- You gotta look at this.
- What's this?
- I play basketball, the guy fouled me,
then he's like, "That wasn't even a foul."
Then I said, "But wait, look at that."
And he's like "Okay, fine."